et
notre invité politique ce matin c'était
l'islam mirnyi bonjour je vous remercie
beaucoup d'être avec nos députés ont
fait tomber les masques vous pouvez les
distances sont respectés déléguée
générale de la république en marche on
est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale bonjour stéphane
bern et bonjour bonjour et fan de ouest
france bien évidemment on va commencer
avec ce déplacement des manuels macron
dans la creuse et en haute-vienne
aujourd'hui déplacement sur le monde de
la réalité on va revenir sur le fond sur
les questions de rivalité mais d'abord
stanislas guérini vous le voyez tous les
commentaires parlent d'un président en
campagne ce qui n'est pas tant clarifier
la situation
moi je croise des journalistes qui me
parle beaucoup d'un président en
campagne j'entends des opposants qui me
campagne je croise un peu moins de
français il a été encerclé par des
jeunes étudiants ont choisi la question
qui est de l' envie que les gens aient
envie de voir le président de la
république continuer son action tant
mieux il a dit lui-même qu'il avait
envie et ensuite je crois qu'il ya
vraiment une forme d'évidence à ce que
le président puisse être candidat ce qui
compte à mon sens c'est le sens à donner
à un prochain quinquennat si les
français continuent de lui faire
confiance ça c'est la question de fond
je vois aujourd'hui une campagne qui est
un peu enlisée parfois l'oeil dans le
rétro où on nous parle beaucoup des
années passées des années sarko du ps
rêvait des années 80 et c'est tard etc
moi je voudrais une campagne qui regarde
la france dans dix ans dans 20 ans dans
trente ans parce que c'est ça qui se
joue pour le pays aujourd'hui je vois
que le seul qui fait cet exercice au
fond de projection du pays y compris
quand il vient parler ruralité quand il
parle l'université quand il parle
sécurité aussi qu il par l'attractivité
de son bilan si on va y revenir mais
juste une impression sur cette cette
ambiguïté c'est une évidence qu'il soit
candidat et candidate à un moment cette
ambiguïté ne risque pas de la cvo
électeurs moi je sincèrement je ne crois
pas vous savez la semaine dernière le
président de la république était au
parlement européen pour lancer la
présidence française de l'union
européenne
c'est un moment je crois qu'il fallait
effectuer en étant pleinement président
de la république donc je crois que on
lui ferait leurs proches inverse
aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup de pression
qui est médiatique et mise sur une
éventuelle candidature la date de
candidature tout le monde est obsédé par
ça les
connaît on dirait avait plus assez
président et c'est donc la vie politique
est faite d'injonction contradictoires
c'est lui qui est le maître des horloges
depuis le début de ce quinquennat et au
fond est-ce qu'il n'est pas en campagne
depuis le début du quinquennat pour
convaincre pour expliquer moi je crois
que c'est comme ça qu'on doit faire la
politique juste une précision cette
injonction contradictoire et ce qu'elles
ne sont pas de nature à compliquer la
vie de vos militants par exemple quand
vous diffuser trois cent mille tracts
pour vanter les mérites des mâles macron
dans son dans son aspect européens comme
le week-end dernier et qui qui tractait
ce que c'est les militants est ce que
c'est le la majorité présidentielle est
ce que ces ensembles citoyen est ce que
c'est chaque formation qui se présente
avec sa propre étiquette non c'est la
majorité présidentielle telle majorité
présidentielle et on le sait c'est le
vocable c'est le cas mais que vous
utilisez oui c'est secondaire on reparle
déclaré luc en marche sur les tracts et
tous les partis de la majorité
présidentielle sont rassemblés justement
pour porter ces idées là savez ce que
c'est un problème est-ce que c'est
compliqué pas du tout moi mais c'est
depuis j'ai moi j'assume pourquoi pas
ensemble citoyens mais la major je vais
d'abord je veux je veux répondre sur le
fait que depuis des mois nous assumons
parfaitement d'être en campagne je suis
venu vous le dire à cette antenne on l'a
fait depuis l'été dernier pour
promouvoir le bilan parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de choses à dire on l'a fait
dans une campagne qui avait un peu fait
causer s'appelait 50 plus le plus pour
les français nous a dit mais vous êtes
déjà en train de vous projeter moi
j'assume parfaitement on a envie que le
président de la république soit candidat
on a envie de continuer cette action
pour le pays et les militants dans
marche du modem d'agir d'oraison de
territoire de progrès de toutes ces
formations qui sont rassemblés vers le
prêt la république elles ont la même
envie donc ça n'est un problème que pour
les commentateurs absolument pas pour
les militants tout le monde ils sont
tous coupables sur les joues en ciel
effectivement on a distribué en quelques
jours trois cent mille tracts 80 mille
affiches pour parler week-end hors
d'europe parce que nous n'avons jamais
reculer sur les valeurs européennes
jamais reculer y compris quand tout le
monde critique et l'europe au démarrage
cette crise sanitaire nous avons
continué à croire en l'europe à
transformer l'europe et nous avons des
résultats laisse vous attendez encore
vous allez franchir un cran quand
emmanuel macron déclarera officiellement
sa candidature ou alors vous êtes déjà
au taquet là je ferais bien mal je
remplirai bien mal mes fonctions à la
tête de la république en marche si je
voudrais pas que on en a encore sous la
cette envie là évidemment elle
est forte et vous verrez qu'elle se
démultipliera encore plus dans les
semaines à venir on va reparler de la
présidentielle bien sûr dans quelques
instants mais pour revenir sur le fond
du déplacement des mails même à cons
parce que ses questions de réalité c'est
important pour les français il a été
interpellé hier par des jeunes sur les
difficultés à vivre dans ces zones
rurales qui lui ont parlé d'isolement de
zones blanches demande d'infrastructures
de difficultés de transport est-ce que
la fracture territoriale qu'ils
voulaient résorber durant son
quinquennat elle est encore là
aujourd'hui bien sûr qui a encore les
difficultés
c'est l'évidence et le président de la
république lui-même le reconnaissait se
trouve que ce qui doit nous caractérise
essaie de regarder exactement le réel de
partir systématiquement de ce qui se
passe sur le terrain beaucoup de choses
ont avancé dans ce quinquennat et moi je
déteste entendre un discours sur la
ruralité qui est un disque au fond de
défaite comme s'ils avaient aucune
solution possible beaucoup de choses ont
été faites présent de la république
aujourd'hui inaugurera la 2000e maison
france service ça ce sont les services
publics reviennent sur les territoires
on parle aussi de bar sur les téléphones
portables de couverture numérique il ya
une accélération inédite dans ce
quinquennat on parle évidemment de
solutions pu être apportée pour le
développement des agriculteurs tout ça
j'aime faire
je dirais manuel macro mon envie de
vivre dans la creuse mais c'est
compliqué ce que vous avez échoué à la
résorber sa trace je pourrais je repars
qu'on ait échoué mais je crois qu'il ya
encore beaucoup de boulot à effectuer
est le plus important peut-être c'est ce
qu'on peut faire pour les jeunes qui
vivent dans la ruralité pour
l'apprentissage par exemple sur les
questions agricoles président de la
république était avec le ministre de
l'agriculture là aussi on a franchi un
pas de géant dans ce quinquennat mais
beaucoup reste à faire pour la ruralité
évidemment il ya eu beaucoup de débats
au cours de ce quinquennat sur la
décentralisation la loi 3ds avec la
différenciation l'expérimentation la
simplification est ce que est ce que est
ce qu est ce que les choses ont vraiment
avancé est ce que la fracture est
résorbé les relations avec les élus se
sont elles améliorées ou alors
finalement est-ce que ce quinquennat n'a
pas été un quinquennat hyper
centralisateur avec un pouvoir qui
restait quand même très verticale non je
crois pas et à l'occasion du dernier
congrès des maires présents de la
république a pu faire la démonstration
des chantiers qui avaient avancé qui
pour beaucoup étaient des chantiers
qu'il considère qu'il a vraiment bloqué
tout va mieux là les élus moi ce que je
constate c'est que la relation avec des
locaux s'est apaisée vrai qu'au début du
quinquennat et une détention souci
peut-être des incompréhensions aussi
mais incertaine dans les comptes de
certaines branches ont été levées et je
pense qu'il a pris le temps d'écouter et
que le fait d'être entouré d'élus
expérimenté d'élus locaux bien ça a été
bénéfique pour ce quinquennat et je
crois que ça a été profondément insulté
pour le président de la république donc
oui il y avait certainement parfois
peut-être parfois même dans la forme des
incompréhensions à lever les choses ont
beaucoup bougé de ce point de vue là
depuis début du quinquennat on va parler
de la crise sanitaire et en députés de
la majorité a été agressé samedi une
nouvelle fois malheureusement on envie
de vous dire à perpignan par des
militants anti passe comment vous
expliquez ce climat de violence dans le
pays notamment sur ce sujet d'abord il
faut jamais l'accepter en mettant des
mets en mettant des explications au fond
ce que j'entends parfois en disant mais
si les propos du président de la
république si la situation sanitaire si
le pass vaccinale est ce que tout ceci
serait pas à l'origine d'actes de
violence mais il faut bien sûr mais vous
vous l'entendez vous même parfois
résidant sur vous plaît en vidant les
non-vaccinés ça apaise pas juste moi
qu'il faut aller d'abord vous me parlez
des violences sur les élus qui peuvent
être des élus locaux qui peuvent être de
la majorité qui peuvent être des élus
d'opposition hélas un député de la
majorité des images extrêmement choquant
c'est une demi heure d'un déferlement de
haine sur un député un conseiller d'un
ministre qui sont dans une permanence
parlementaire à l'ecoute et au contact
de nos concitoyens donc d'abord n'ayons
pas d'ambiguïté les gens qui sont en
face de ces élus là ce sont des gens qui
n'aiment pas la démocratie et ça doit
nous ramener au fond à cette idée là tu
la démocratie c'est une valeur une
notion un principe qui est fragile quand
on regarde notre histoire faut pas que
la démocratie se soit une parenthèse
c'est pas majoritaire dans le monde la
démocratie mais ce qu'il faut doit elle
mesure de rassembler au delà des mots
qui évidemment ce bien sûr l'histoire il
faut qu'il faut dire que c'est l'âge et
les élus et c'est là l'essentiel
donc il faut systématiquement agir vous
avez vu que le président de l'assemblée
nationale a indiqué que l'assemblée
systématiquement se porterait partie
civile il ya d'ailleurs des poursuites
qui sont engagés le ministre de
l'intérieur et le garde des sceaux sont
extrêmement engagés sur ce que les
maires demandent la même chose par la
vague bien sûr mais vous savez que dans
la loi justement comment voter qui
concerne les collectivités locales
engagement et proximité nous avons fait
des avancées là aussi pour mieux
protéger les mères pour que l'état
puisse se substituer aux mères parfois
pour les défendre particulièrement dans
des petites communes 9 15 ans en 1986
elle devait dernière floraison pas
suffisant mais ce que je dis c'est que
il faut agir à tous les étages c'est ce
média dans la protection dans les
poursuites que ceux qui se livrent à des
actes comme comme ça ces actes de
violence sache qui a pas d'impunité
derrière mais il faut aussi s'intéresser
aux causes racines et les causes racines
c'est l'éducation c'est la défense de la
démocratie s'intéressait aussi à ce qui
se passe sur les réseaux sociaux
pas ne pas faire le lien entre les fakes
news ce qu'on met dans la tête de
personnes sont parfois moins éduqués à
travers les réseaux sociaux qu'on laisse
circuler sans régulation parfois et ces
déversements de la nouvelle loi sur la
régulation des contenus oui je les
réseaux sociaux je crois que ça ça fait
partie des grands enjeux pour le futur
voyez ce qui se passe au niveau européen
nous en parlions il ya quelques instants
les lignes sont en train de bouger
profondément et à dans la présence
française de l'union européenne cet
objectif là de pouvoir avancer et nous
le faisons avec notamment le commissaire
thierry breton avec cédric au le
ministre en charge du numérique pour
mieux régler plateforme c'est un enjeu
de société au fond que de maîtriser nos
données personnelles de maîtriser et de
réguler les plateformes numériques tout
ça n'est pas sans incidence sur le monde
réel ont parlé du passé sanitaire juste
une question rapide vous lui demanderez
à l'entrée des meetings de la république
en marche et la majorité présidentielle
alors moi je respecterai absolument la
décision du conseil constitutionnel le
conseil constitutionnel a dit façon très
claire que un organisateur de meeting
politique ne pouvait pas demander le
pass vaccinale donc je ne demanderai pas
le pass vaccinale avec un qui
souhaiteraient entrer dans un meeting
dans un rassemblement parce que le
conseil compte un seul l'a dit moi je
respecte sur les décisions en revanche
ce que je peux vous dire c'est nous
continuerons à inciter fortement toutes
celles et ceux qui font le choix ou qui
feront le choix de venir dans lé
rassemblement de la majorité
présidentielle à se munir du pass
vaccinale parce que je crois je continue
de croire que c'est la clé absolue pour
sortir de cette crise sanitaire va
sortir de la pandémie avant l'avant la
présidentielle je souhaite de tout mon
coeur et j'y croise aussi des éléments
qui voulait ça on a les mêmes éléments
je crois sur la table
on voit qu'il ya un taux d'incidence
aujourd'hui qui est très élevée en corps
et que la situation dans la réanimation
ce qui est au fond le juge de paix dans
cette crise sanitaire laisse penser
qu'on va pouvoir justement à voir une
amélioration
c'est pour ça que c'était utile je crois
de prolonger les mesures de restriction
le télétravail les jauges le masque et
en même temps de donner des perspectives
d'assouplissement parce que il ya une
perte aggravée en circulation du virus
très forte incidence très forte
réanimation qui tienne je crois que
c'est à peu près la clé comprendre la
situation telle qu'elle est sous nos
yeux
évidemment les français c'est la hausse
des prix et notamment la hausse des prix
du carburant oui les prix de l'essence
et du gazole bat bat tous les records on
avait bruno le maire sur ce plateau
vendredi dernier qui me disait que que
des travaux internes à bercy serait
conduit ce week-end par rapport à ces
questions est ce que ce que vous servez
ce qui va sortir du chapeau et qui aura
des nouvelles mesures hors jeu c'est
petite idée le petit doigt qui dit des
choses non ce que je sais et c'est
évidemment bonne chose nécessaire le
gouvernement travaille aux solutions
techniques pour continuer à accompagner
nos concitoyens comme nous l'avons fait
depuis le début de cette crise sur les
prix de l'énergie pour le gaz pour
l'électricité je fais remarquer au
passage que les français sont beaucoup
mieux protégés que nos voisins européens
regardez l'inflation qui est en grande
partie explicable par la hausse des prix
de l'énergie elle est beaucoup plus
forte deux à trois fois plus forte chez
nos voisins européens parce que nous
avons pris des décisions sur le bouclier
tarifaire sur l'effort demandé à edf
notamment partagé avec l'état chaque
invocation à des prix de l'électricité
le chèque inflation ces quatre milliards
d'euros vous directement c'est ce qui
est adressé aux français c'est ce qui
explique qu'on n'est pas un retour de
flamme un retour de gilet jaune par
exemple parce que là le le prix de
l'essence est encore plus élevé que
qu'en 2018 moi ce que je crois c'est que
globalement dans cette crise il valait
mieux être français que citoyen de
n'importe quel autre pays dans le monde
parce que les français ont été mieux
protégés et je vois là aussi nous
parlions d'injonction contradictoires
parfois dans la vie politique du pays
celles et ceux qui nous disent le lundi
matin trouver des solutions baisser les
taxes des solutions en milliards d'euros
et puis qui le mardi matin viennent sur
les mêmes bases de télévision dire ils
crament la caisse ils font de la
politique avec le carnet de chèques nous
nous savons quelle est notre boussole
c'est le pouvoir d'achat des français
quand on regarde chaque énergie le
chèque inflation le bouclier tarifaire
l'ensemble des aides qui ont été
apportées pendant la crise à travers le
quoi qu'il en coûte nous n'avons jamais
perdu cette boussole là et nous allons
continuer d'accompagner de protéger nos
concitoyens sur le cbs année 16 gagné
puisque le conseil d'état a suspendu
hier l'interdiction de vente de fleurs
de cannabis décidées par le gouvernement
depuis le 1er janvier c'est un revers
pour vous
non je crois que on peut avoir beaucoup
de débat sur la légalisation du cannabis
y en a ils compris dans la majorité 36'
parlement oui c'est vrai sur le cbd sur
les drogues dites douces parfois moi je
crois que quand on mène une politique
publique qui a un objectif pour le coup
qui est partagé par tout le monde c'est
à dire de baisser la consommation de
lutter contre les trafiquants on peut
pas à la fois appuyé sur le frein et sur
l'accélérateur en même temps et donc moi
je comprends la position du gouvernement
je la soutiens une position claire pour
mettre la priorité sur la lutte contre
elle pour vous une gouvernement doit
retravailler pour interdire à nouveau
cette vente oui moi je crois que le
gouvernement doit rester cohérent parce
que en sagesse quand il s'agit de drogue
il faut mener des politiques publiques
constante et cohérente on va parler de
la présidentielle est d'abord d'eric
zemmour qui était en meeting à cannes ça
10 soir il a longuement parlé fait
plusieurs propositions mais je vous ai
interrogé sur une île à ils vont
introduire s'il est élu la notion de
défense excusable c'est à dire qu'un
commerçant qui est attaqué pour y poster
un policier qui est attaqué pour
riposter qu'est ce que vous pensez de ce
à quoi je crois que eric zemmour est
dans une sorte de spirale de la
radicalité des propositions qui vont au
fond orthez choqué le plus et qui
s'intéresse bien moins à résoudre
vraiment les problèmes des français que
à faire une sorte de marketing de
l'extrême droite voyaient dans cette
primaire qui est là sous nos yeux donc
les propositions seront chaque jour un
peu plus excessives au fond très
éloignés des possibilités réelles de
régler les problèmes je crois que ses
traits à l'image de ce que déversent
eric zemmour dans cette campagne depuis
le début puisque son marketing de
l'extrême droite pour reprendre
l'expression que venait d'utiliser peut
lui permettre de faire l'union des
droites
savez moi je suis pas le commentateur je
vois que j'ai vu que le précédent
mercato de l'extrême droite de cette
union des droites etc certaine façon
c'est leur problème
ce que je vois c'est qu'il ya
effectivement beaucoup d'ambiguïtés il
ya à droite au fond des fractures qui
sont assez profonde y compris chez les
républicains même s'il essaye de les
dissimuler aujourd'hui est bien peu de
constance dans les convictions moi ce
qui m'intéresse c'est de proposer aux
français au fond l'espace le plus
cohérent dans la vie politique du pays
le plus stable aussi qu'un espace
central c'est comme ça on va continuer à
changer le pays pas en nous intéressant
à ce qui peut se passer plus à la droite
que la droite je suis les républicains
pourtant pour l'instant on a observé le
guide de départ de guillaume pelletier
on peut pour de fin du passé alquier
passées des républicains cheryl zemmour
on peut pas vraiment parler d'hémorragie
là pour le coup je suis pas une
hémorragie que je suis en train de
commenter mais ce que je vois c'est
assez étonnant de voir les réactions
suite au départ de guillaume pelletier
au fond les uns et les autres mais on
pas dit tu pars défendre une ligne qui
est totalement différente de la nôtre
regardez eric ciotti son entourage leur
réaction c'est de dire au fond tu va
nous empêcher de faire gagner la droite
parce que valérie pécresse elle est
mieux placé pour battre macron que eric
zemmour ou que marine le pen comme si
tout ceci au fond n'était qu'une
stratégie pour battre macron c'est ça le
dénominateur commun
je pense que c'est très inquiétant pour
la droite en réalité parce que bien
longtemps la droite a défendu des
valeurs qui était à l'opposé l'extrême
droite y avait un mur extrêmement
importants travaux assez extrême droite
galeo jours on voit bien qu'à des
difficultés de lignes qui sont
apparentes quand le premier soutien de
valérie pécresse c'est eric ciotti qui
dit qu'il voterait zemmour plutôt que
emmanuel macron deuxième tour et ça doit
interroger quand même les électeurs
d'une droite humanistes républicaines
éclairez moi je pense difficultés de
lignes majeures aujourd'hui chez les
élèves et au fond on voit bien que la
candidate des républicains mais elle
doit faire avec tous les bouts de
l'omelette et bien ça ça empêche de
porter un ossuaire de ces propositions
qu'elle implique la savate défiscaliser
les successions jusqu'à deux cent mille
euros au lieu de 100 mille euros
aujourd'hui c'est une bonne idée ça pour
vous moi ce que je crois sur le débat
que je vois sur l'héritage c'est qu'il
faut de l'efficacité et la stabilité
l'efficacité ça peut être effectivement
d'avoir des réflexions pour faciliter
les donations sur les petits patrimoines
et de nations aussi du vivant non pas
des cessions pour moi je suis plutôt
favorable c'est un avis personnel peut
se donne là à ce qu'on puisse regarder
pour pouvoir donner plus facilement tout
au long de la vie aujourd'hui quand on
regarde on hérite beaucoup plus tard
dans les années que nous sommes en train
de vivre qu'il ya 30 ans c'était 40 45
en moyenne les années 80 c'est plutôt 55
ans aujourd'hui donc facilitons la
circulation dans l'économie de l'argent
pour que des grands parents des parents
puissent donner plus facilement et
stabilité c'est de ne pas augmenter les
impôts nous avons une politique
économique qui marche qui est une
politique de baisse des impôts sur les
ménages de baisse des impôts sur les
entreprises je crois d'ailleurs qu'il
faudra poursuivre cette politique là
parce qu'elle donne des résultats parce
qu'elle permet de créer des emplois
parce qu'elle rend la france compétitive
et donc n'augmentons pas les impôts et
facilite les choses du vivant à mon avis
il ya là une voie qui est une voie
d'efficacité vous avez évoqué à
l'instant des difficultés de ligne à
droite comment ça se passe chez vous il
n'y a pas discuté ligne pourriez-vous
préciser où habitait devoir philippin
coulé dans la maison commune à couillet
pluie revient je ne sais pas beaucoup
lice sur quel ton vous dans quelle
langue edouard philippe devra dire qu'il
soutient pleinement le président de la
république pour pouvoir être fait qui
a apporté la fusion entre à gérer
horizon d'en écouter sas vont
conviendrait quand même que les affaires
de fusions d'intégration statutaire
entre différents partis de la majorité
pas être qualifié de fractures ou des
difficultés sur la ligne il ya
aujourd'hui quelque chose qui est très
net c'est que nous sommes tous
rassemblés derrière le président de la
république peut l'avons affirmé haut et
fort il ya quelques semaines à peine
c'était à la mutualité où nous avons
donné cette image assez inédite dans la
vie politique du pays d'une force
centrale de la majorité présentielle
totalement parce
qu' aucune ambiguïté ce matin je m'en
voudrais expliquer votre plateau a été
ambiguë sur ce thème là tout le monde
edouard philippe françois bayrou tous
les dirigeants de la
maison
on peut on peut faire la politique en
ayant le sourire quand on est rassembler
et comporte un projet optimiste
volontariste pour le pays ça aussi c'est
un peu inédit dans la vie politique du
pt fondé sur un sondage au doxa pour les
chaînes parlementaires et la presse
régionale publié ce matin qui compare
edouard philippe et emmanuel cros et le
plébiscite pour edouard philippe 66% des
français font davantage confiance à
edouard philippe k emmanuel macron 59%
pensent qu'ils doivent finit pas plus la
stature d'un homme d'état et 61% pensent
qu'il sera meilleur président de la
république qu'est ce que vous en pensez
je pense que ces questions n'ont
absolument aucun sens pardonnez moi
parce que c'est un sondage que vous avez
commenté ou commander plus tôt c'est moi
qu'ils commentent mais ça n'a aucun sens
parce que on compte pas quelqu'un qui a
été premier ministre qui a été un
excellent point miss vous avez compris
que mon soutien a toujours été pleins et
entiers avec un président en exercice
voyez les lé baromètre des personnalités
politiques telles questions à mesure
aujourd'hui celles qui sont généralement
plus haut celles qui sont complètement
retiré de la vie politique ça n'est pas
le cas d'edouard philippe qui est le
maire du havre et un chef de parti mais
on voit bien que ce sont des sondages
qui sont totalement insignifiant et je
vous dis ça en étant un soutien fervent
du président de la république
et maintenant
[Musique]